when you look at a rain forest ecosystem
like this one of the obvious questions
may be where do these plants come from
how do they grow they're growing all the
time getting larger and larger and
larger where does that mass where does
that matter come from pause this video
and think about that
well you might already be guessing where
it comes from it might have something to
do with photosynthesis which we go into
a lot of depth in other videos but this
is a process where you have carbon
dioxide
from the air in conjunction with water
that primarily is coming from the soil
and it uses energy from the sun so i'll
just draw that as these yellow squiggles
coming from the sun in order to do two
things the plant is going to be building
itself using the matter and the carbon
dioxide in the water while also
expelling oxygen as a byproduct and this
matter that the plant is able to take
from its environment with photosynthesis
is used to both become the structure of
the plant and a store of energy in the
form of sugars
now animals like you and me we get our
energy by then eating these plants and
how do we unlock that energy
well that's where this oxygen is really
useful that's why we need to breathe
oxygen because by breathing the oxygen
we can essentially do photosynthesis in
reverse and we can break down this
matter these sugars that we're getting
from plants so all of this biomass is
coming from essentially water from the
soil and carbon dioxide and energy from
the sun is used essentially put it
together there might be a few other
nutrients that are also coming from the
environment like the soil but primarily
the water and the carbon dioxide